So what I want to do today is continue our discussion on AI project strategy.
So if you're building a deep learning system for some tasks, and today, for the first
part of today, I'm going to use a speech recognition, voice-activated device example.
And then for the second half, I'm going to use a kind of AI deep researcher example.
But what I want to do is walk you through a couple of concrete examples of projects
you might work on and let you understand what it feels like to be in the thick of
building an AI system, making day-to-day decisions on what to do next.
I find that, I think as you've heard me say before, understanding the
algorithms is important, so in this class, you learn a lot from the
online videos about the deep learning algorithms, how to build pipelines.
But even beyond understanding how the algorithms work, what really drives
performance is a team's ability to have an efficient development process.
How do you tune how the parameters, how do you collect data?
When you try something and it doesn't work the first time, which it often
doesn't, what do you do next?
Your skill at making those decisions is what often makes a massive,
literally 10x difference in productivity.
And as I was reflecting, was preparing for what to say to you today,
I was reflecting on quite a few projects where that 10x difference in
productivity is really not an exaggeration, right?
Maybe more than 10x, but I've literally seen many teams in many well-known
companies with good brands spend a year at work on a project that I will
see a more skilled team execute in like a month, right?
So these differences in skill are real.
And one of the challenges for new people learning this is if you
work for some company, maybe you work on a different project every year or two,
right? But so it takes you like, you know, two years of two years or a year of your
life to gain experience on one more project.
And then after, I don't know, 10 years, you finally seen 10 projects
and a pretty experience.
But what I want to do is in today's class, walk you through a few
concrete examples of projects that similar to want to kind of simplify
versions of stuff that I've seen myself to try to accelerate your hands
on experience, looking at these projects and thinking through.
If you are the one in the hot seat building a system and it works or
doesn't work or this problem, whatever, making those decisions for what you
would do. So try to get you through that today.
We'll have a couple of examples rather than you having to spend years
and years of your life to finally see a small number of examples of how
these projects can be driven.
Right? So the first motive, the first of the two motivating examples
I'm going to use today is building a voice activated device in my house.
I have, you know, like a Amazon Echo, right?
I have a lot of them actually.
And I think it's a delightful experience, but those devices like
that, Amazon Echo or Google Home or the Apple Siri HomePods, they
require quite a bit of setup, right?
They require some setup, connect to the wifi, figure out a way to
connect to your phone, blah.
And so, you know, actually for a long time, even though I built smart
speakers, for a long time in my house, I had one light bulb connected
to my home wifi internet, you know, because it's just so much of
a hassle to set things up.
I think now I have two light bulbs connected in my house.
I guess I should connect my stuff.
But so for this motive example, I want to talk about if you are
part of a startup, building a new product that makes it much easier
to get these voice control devices without the user needing to do
this whole wifi setup process.
So, you know, I'm not very good at drawing, but if you could go to
some store and buy a desk lamp and the desk lamp already has a name,
let's call this lamp Robert, and you could just take it, plug it into
the electricity, plug it into your desk, and then say, Robert, turn
on, and then it turns on, say, Robert, turn on, then it turns off
without needing to be connected to the internet, to the cloud
access and all that.
Then that would give users an easier setup experience.
There's a project that my friends and I actually discussed a
few years ago that we thought would actually be a decent startup
idea.
We decided not to do it because there are too many other ideas
that we're even more excited about.
But we felt that actually, you know, like a reasonable, reasonable
startup idea to build a little IC circuit, little integrated
circuit, to sell to say, lamp manufacturers and other device
manufacturers to make it really easy if, say, some company
sells lamps to build little things so they can very quickly
make their devices voice enabled.
And if you have a few pre-built names, maybe give the
users a choice, you can call it lamp Robert or Lainer, you
know, or, I don't know, or Johnny or, I don't know,
Alice or whatever, have a little switch.
Then users could just buy a lamp, put it down, and then
immediately have it be voice controlled without needing to
worry about how do you get this onto my Wi-Fi network?
And if my internet is down, then my whole house stays
dark as well because all things like that, right?
And I actually did once have an, I was building a lot
of voice assistants, I actually set up my office to
have a lot of voice control devices.
So I had different names with different lamps, standing
desk is his name as well, so I'd say, I forget what my
desk name was, you know, like, you know, Jonathan, go
higher or whatever, and then my standing desk would go
up and down.
It's actually pretty cool.
So what I want you to, so just for today's
illustration, probably we should give the different
devices different names because you can't have every
device in your house called Robert.
Otherwise, they say Robert turn on the whole house
illuminates and Robert turn off whole houses plunged into
the darkness.
So we found out you do need different devices to
have different names.
But just for today, I'm going to use as illustration,
the task of creating a neural network or building
a system that detects when someone says Robert
turn on, and you need kind of Robert turn on,
Robert turn off.
If you have a choice, it needs to be Lena turn on,
Lena turn off and a variety of handful of options
of names.
But just a simplicity, I'm going to worry only about
detecting the phrase Robert turn on, right?
And what do we do for this?
You can rinse and repeat to get the turn off
command and a handful of other names to make it
user selectable.
What, you know, what name do you want to give this
thing?
Okay, so this is something they'll need to run on
device, small IC circuits, and Mike, and I'm going
to ask you a question, right?
When you've graduated from CS230, or maybe when
you graduated from Stanford, if you are the
CTO of a startup responsible for building
this, what would you do?
Right?
So call out.
So imagine you just graduated from CS230 or
just graduate from Stanford, and you're the CTO
of a startup, and you want to build this lamp that
can turn on when anyone says Robert turn on.
How would you approach this problem?
And I know this is an incredibly open-ended
question, and it turns out life is incredibly
open-ended, right?
You graduate from CS230, you have to decide
what to do.
So if this is what you're doing, if you're
going to raise your hand and call out, if you
want to build this product, what's the first
thing you do?
How would you think about it?
Go for it.
Yeah, cool.
Yeah, right.
So get some like an open-source speech-to-text
model or something, and let's see if you can
write it.
Yeah, that would be a good start.
Anything else?
Go ahead.
All right, sorry.
Three models, one that detects Robert, and
then one that I see.
I see.
Cool.
Right.
Okay.
So the three models to detect Robert,
understand their sentence, or detecting
the sound.
Cool.
Go for it.
All right.
Oh, sorry.
Say again?
It's like a sign-means network.
We actually teach a sign-means network
related to this class, where something
that inputs two audio files and decides
they're saying the same words.
So you can more easily generalize the
new words than the Robert.
Cool.
Now that's actually pretty interesting.
Yeah, go for it.
Oh, sorry.
You mean just connect up your device
to Siri?
I see.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
Right.
That sounds interesting.
It sounds like a different product
than this if we need to connect to
the cell phone and all that though.
Yeah.
Cool.
Right.
So let me just, lots of interesting
ideas.
Let me just make some observations.
So I find that when building software
products, there are actually lots of
good ideas or lots of reasonable things
you could try.
But, you know, as you heard me
mention a few weeks ago, I think one
of the strongest predictors for the
odds of you building something compelling
is speed.
So I find that of all of these ideas,
I think some are better than others,
but it doesn't, but whether the idea
is, you know, a bit better, a little
bit worse, it is important.
But it's actually secondary to how
quickly you can just get something
built.
So if you're actually the CTO of a
startup like this, I encourage you to
look and say, all right, what can
we build today?
Or what can we build maybe in a week?
And try any of these architecture
choices and build it
and see what happens.
Because even if what you build is a
little bit less, you know, good,
you can find out all in two days,
you know, leaving the course
correct very quickly.
I've actually worked, I've actually
built a lot of smart speakers.
So I have maybe firsthand experience
of this and I just share some
things that I happen to know that
there's no reason you would know.
But it turns out that, let's see,
at least today, general purpose
speech recognition is still a little
bit heavyweight.
Takes quite a lot of, you know,
processing power is a bit expensive
to run on an edge device.
If you want to make this like
just a few dollars.
But it turns out that if you look
at the smart speakers, there's
usually, if you want to train
a neural network just to detect
one phrase, be it a phrase like,
you know, okay, Google, or hey,
Siri, or Alexa, or whatever.
And if the smart speaker
trigger words, that can be done
with a fairly small neural network.
Although to your point, if we want
to do different neural networks,
different words, we'll need to swap
out different neural networks.
I'm going to repeat that.
But if you have only a small
handful of names, phrases,
one to ten, I think that'd be okay.
And then one other piece of advice
I would give, if you're embarking
on this, is the first thing I
would do actually, if I was working
on this for the first time, is
actually a literature search.
And it turns out that, you know,
I think we're fortunate that the AI
world has a ton of open-source
software and a ton of open
research papers.
Somewhat surprisingly, despite
smart speakers haven't been
around for a long time,
there still, to this day, isn't
like a single architecture that
everyone's agreed on, on the
best way to do this.
If you look at the literature,
there's still actually a
diversity of opinions on how to do
this type of wake word or trigger
word, which is so sensitive.
So when you say something like,
yeah, okay, Google, or Hey Siri,
or Alexa, that's sometimes called
a wake word because it wakes up
the device, or trigger word,
triggers the device to take
activity. So somewhat
surprisingly, even though we
have smart speakers for a long
time now, for more than a decade,
there still isn't a single agreed
on unified architecture that
the committee has agreed on,
and what's the best algorithm
to do this. But I feel like
if you are embarking on this
for the first time, the number
one boost in your speed of
learning, it could be
implementing something, but I
would say doing a literature
search and trying open source
software would be the even
faster accelerator.
And I want to give you a few
tips for that, right?
Real quick. So, you know,
today, if this is, there are
a lot of research articles
and blog posts and GitHub repos
on many topics, certainly wake
word detection. And what I
find is that if this is
research paper one, research
paper two, research paper
three, research paper four,
I find that, you know,
sometimes people will spend
a lot of time reading
research paper one until
you're done, right?
It's zero percent complete,
it's a hundred percent
complete. And then spend
a lot of time reading
research paper two, spend
research paper three, and I
just recommend you not do
that. Instead, when I'm
doing a literature search,
what it often feels like is,
you know, do a few web
searches for a handful
of resources, skim all
of them, zero percent
complete, hundred percent
complete, right?
Basically initial reading,
you may decide to go back
to paper three and spend
more time to really read
and understand that.
But that'll help you find
additional references,
you can skim and maybe
you find that paper seven
that's really seminal,
spend a lot of effort.
But this is what doing
a very broad survey of
the literature will feel like,
where, you know, you're
really putting the time
to finish only a very small
number of resources, but spend
a lot more time skipping
around and getting a
cursory level understanding
of a broader set of papers,
which can also point you
to also point you
to the more useful resources
to focus attention on.
And just one thing
I've seen among Stanford
students, there's one
other thing that I find
people tend to under use,
which is trying to talk
to experts. So if you are
actually a seat at a start,
I'm trying to build this
for the first time.
I feel like, you know,
we all want to do our own work
and not bother other people,
which is good.
But I just encourage you
to consider if
after you've done your own work,
if reach out to an expert
can really survey your learning.
So something I've often done is,
you know, I will do my own work.
I don't call random experts
to try to bother them
before I've at least done my work.
But if you've sometimes
I'm reading a paper,
I'm really struggling
to understand it.
And I find that instead of me
struggling for another like
four hours, if I send the authors
a respectful email
and say, hey, I read your paper,
try to understand this.
I'm still confused.
Can you help me out?
Can you explain this to me?
A lot of the time,
including when, you know,
I was less well known, right?
But I think a lot of people,
if they see that
you're doing your work
and not just reaching out to them
before you've even done anything,
a lot of them, not everyone,
but a lot of research authors
would actually be quite, you know,
understanding and then
try to help you out.
And so I find that
for a lot of projects I did,
finding that one expert,
sometimes a Stanford professor,
actually we have a lot of speech faculty
and the Stanford faculty as well.
But when I had problems
with my speech recognition system,
you know, sometimes I call like,
you know, Dan Jurowski, whatever.
And then like a half hour conversation
or even a 10 minute conversation
really accelerates
what I've been able to do.
So I just encourage you to,
it takes you like 10 minutes
to send an email
and maybe there's a 50% chance
of response, I don't know, right?
Not a high spin chance,
but sometimes that tends to be
really high ROI, right?
And then what I think you find
is that if you do
a literature search,
you will likely discover
that most of the robust enterprise
grade smart speaker systems
all have a specialized system
trained to detect the wake word
or the trigger word, right?
And again, there's a variety
of architectures.
You probably come up
with some good neural network
architectures for this.
And oh, it turns out that
there is no data set on the internet
with lots of people
saying Robert turned on, right?
That's just not a thing, right?
So if you decide that the names
are Robert and Lainer and,
you know, I don't know,
Jeremy and Alicia or whatever,
sorry, the people of those real names.
It was actually kind of weird
when we chose people's names,
but we chose that for some reason.
But it turns out that
there is no large data set
on the internet of lots of people
saying Robert turned on.
So if you want to train a neural network
to detect if someone has said this phrase,
you need to collect that data yourself, right?
So let me then ask you
another question.
Say you've done a literature search,
found some open source code
you can try,
but that has led you,
say to conclude that
you need data sets
of people saying Robert turned on.
Oh, you need a data set to train
to distinguish between
someone saying Robert turned on
versus not someone saying Robert turned on.
How would you approach
getting a data set like that?
So yeah, go for it.
Text-to-speech.
Yeah, cool.
Yeah, yep.
You use text-to-speech as one method.
I'll come back to that later.
So you need that, yes.
Oh, sorry.
Yep, cool.
Yep, I like that.
So walk around and ask people,
tell them what you're doing,
get the permission to record
and use their voice,
and if they're okay giving permission,
just record their voices.
Yeah, I like that.
Anything else?
Cool.
Oh, sorry.
Can you say that again?
Yep, cool.
Yeah, yep, cool.
Yep, right.
So samples of people
saying not Robert turned on.
I agree, yeah, cool.
I see, cool.
Actually, you're right.
So the data is what people are saying Robert,
but you don't want that to be mistaken.
That's a good point.
I'll come back to that later.
Yes.
Did I say something?
Oh, same thing.
Oh, interesting.
Cool.
Awesome.
Great.
All right.
So one of the...
Yes, so I really like the idea
of just going around
and asking people for permission
to record their voices.
And then, by the way,
in today's world privacy is important.
Consent is important.
So don't do anything sneaky or weird.
Just tell people clearly what you're doing,
ask them for permission,
make sure any permission is freely given,
and if they don't give permission, it's fine.
We won't.
I really respect people's privacy.
That is really important.
Having said that,
I find that a lot of people in the world
are very nice.
Not everyone,
but the vast majority of people in the world
seem very nice.
And if you ask them nicely,
I know this because I've done this myself.
They won't give permission
for you to provide their data.
And then just one of the framing
I encourage you to think about as always
is the speed.
So how long will it take you
to wander around campus
or wander around San Francisco
and collect a sample of voices?
And I think you actually get a lot done.
You'll get many dozens of samples,
maybe hundreds of samples
easily in a day.
So I think those are good tactics.
And then let me share with you some things.
It turns out synthetic data
using text-to-speech
is an interesting tactic.
I would usually not use that
as the first thing I do,
mainly because it turns out
it's hard to know
how accurate synthetic data is
compared to true natural data.
And maybe just show you
one thing I've run into.
I've actually done a lot of synthetic data
for speech recognition, right?
One thing you have to watch out for is
if it goes to a lot of the synthetic
sources of data,
how many voices,
how many different voices
does it provide?
And is it going to be a pain
to get enough diversity
in different people's voices?
So it turns out, I don't know,
for example, I often talk to
open that voice on my phone
instead of typing,
but the number of voices there is limited.
And if you go to TTS provider,
I guess there are now some services
with a larger number of voices,
but these are things
you end up worrying about.
And it's all solvable.
Synthetic data does work
for speech recognition, right?
But it turns out that they're often
enough details associated with filling
with the synthetic data generation process
and that ends up taking longer.
So for a lot of machine learning applications,
using synthetic data is a good idea.
And eventually you might get around to it,
but using synthetic data
is usually not the first type of data
I would collect
because usually there's just
too many hyperparameters
and too many knobs
you have to worry about.
And then at the back of your head,
you may be wondering
whether there's something
weird about the synthetic data
that I had not thought of before.
Whereas you collect natural data,
collect real data,
it's just one less thing to worry about.
Maybe just to tell one more story,
not in speech,
but self-driving cars, right?
So you're building self-driving cars,
you want to detect other cars.
Where do you get pictures of cars?
It turns out that a lot of people
will have the idea of,
oh, there are lots of video games
with cars driving around.
Why don't we use video games
to get pictures of cars
out of the video game?
But it turns out a problem
with a lot of video games is
there could be like 20 different cars
in the entire video game.
It depends on the video game.
But it turns out that
to have a realistic video game,
you don't need a thousand different cars
and there are tons of different
car designs on the road,
but you need a very narrow set of cars.
And so to a human,
seeing the same 20 cars over and over
and looking at the road looks fine,
the video game plays fine.
But for a lot of video games,
the data just isn't rich enough
to capture anywhere near
the richness of the real world.
Whereas in contrast,
if you've got real pictures,
there's just one less thing
you have to worry about, right?
So I find that for synthetic data,
it works, it's very valuable to use it a lot,
but I usually get to it
only later in the process.
Does that make sense?
Cool, something.
And then in the interest
of building these things quickly,
let me share with you
the types of things
that my teams have done
to collect data for this, right?
And I feel like when you
read research papers
or you take courses,
often you get a very clean view of data.
I'm going to tell you
about one of the weird random hacks
that one of my teams has used to build
like a very serious,
working really well
commercial system, right?
And at least that's part
of the journey to do so,
which is, let's see.
So collected 100 training audio clips
and 25 development sets to tune to
and zero tests, right?
One thing I'll often do
if my main goal
is to just build a system that works
as opposed to publish a research paper
is to not have a test set.
We just have a dev set
that we will tune the parameters to.
And if I want to publish a research paper,
I probably need a clean,
unbiased test set.
But if my goal is to just build something
and have it work and ship it,
sometimes I just say,
I'm not going to bother
to collect any test data.
Just a training set and a dev set
and I just unapologetically
tune my system to the dev set, right?
And one thing you could do is,
let's see.
So audio clips.
So audio is, let's see.
So you may have seen the audio waveforms, right?
Which ones is time,
you know, x-axis is time
and audio waveforms kind of
are these wiggly time series.
Right, and sound is very rapid
vibrations in the air
that your ear perceives that sound.
And what the microphone does
is it records these very rapid
changes in air pressure, right?
So that's why I see audio waveforms
that look like this.
And so one thing that
one of my teams once did
was collect 100 samples of,
you know, audio waveforms
where somewhere in the middle of it
is someone saying, Robert, turn on.
So, you know, hey, how are you doing?
Oh, yep.
And let's say Robert turn on
and we could now talk about some other things, right?
And so the phrase Robert turn on
takes about one second to say.
And one way to collect
a constructive training set would be
to take a three second clip.
So this is where Robert turn on was said.
This is where they just finished
saying Robert turn on.
And so if you collect
100 audio clips like this,
one way to turn this into
bigger training set is
to take these long audio clips
and then this becomes a training example
with a label one,
because that's an utterance
where the end of utterances
corresponds to when someone
just finished saying Robert turn on.
And in contrast,
this would be an example,
you know, would be a negative example.
Um, and this too is a negative example,
you know, and this too is a negative example.
Does it make sense?
So given a, say, 10 second clip,
given the 10 seconds of audio,
we will have cut out
a phrase where
you get a positive label
if that three second audio
corresponds to someone just finishing
saying Robert turn on,
which is when you should turn on the lamp
and anything else is labeled zero, right?
And so this is a way to take, say,
100 training examples
and turn that into
3,000 binary examples.
So 100 audio clips, sorry,
I should say 100 audio clips.
And if we take 30 windows out of this,
then you can turn this into,
say, 3,000 training examples
equal to binary zero one label
that labels is this moment in time
when someone just finished
saying the phrase Robert turn on.
So it turns out that if you do this
and we did do this,
then we wound up,
let's see,
we wound up with a system.
So we ran this and tested this on the
depth set.
And we wound up with a system
that when trained to predict binary classification
was 97% accurate, right?
But it turns out it did this
by outputting zero all the time
that had zero detections, right?
And so what this training said,
we basically trained a very large neural network
where I would have gotten
exactly the same result
with that one line of Python code, right?
So this is the kind of stuff
that happens in real life, right?
And by the way,
I'm sharing these stories
not just to entertain you,
though hopefully you're entertained,
but because I think of this
by living these experiences
that you go,
oh, I could see this problem.
This is what I do.
I could see this problem.
So the question to you is,
if you collect this data,
train the system 97% accuracy,
isn't that fantastic?
But you realize that
you just implemented
by a huge neural network
a print zero statement
or the equivalent of print zero
that is never finding
the phrase Robert Turnon.
What do you do next?
What's going on?
Cool. Awesome. Right.
So it increases the number
of Robert Turnons in the training example.
This is a very unbalanced training example
and it's great,
but just saying,
I never hear this phrase, right?
How would you go about,
and you or anyone else,
how would you go about
increasing the number of positive examples?
How do you do that?
Oh, audio editors.
I see. Wow.
I see. Cool.
Yeah. I see.
Okay. Yes.
That will work.
It gets the synthetic data again, right?
Which is actually,
which actually works.
And then it also has
all the complexities of synthetic data,
but it turns out it does work.
So I know it works,
because I've done that too, but yeah.
I see. Okay.
Yeah. Yep.
That works too.
So one thing you could do
is take your positive examples,
the examples of Robert Turnon
and just duplicate those examples,
or maybe just give those examples
more weight to the training objective.
Any other ideas?
Increase the noise of the example.
Yeah. Yeah. Cool.
Yeah. That, that, that, yeah.
So a few variations of synthetic variation.
Yep.
So I think the, the, the easy things to try,
one would be to take the examples and duplicate it, right?
So, you know, mathematically,
this is equivalent to taking your positive examples
and just making multiple copies of that in your training set.
It turns out that will work.
They'll largely solve it.
And by the way, unbalanced data sets
is a common issue in training neural networks.
I'll tell you the rule of thumb I use.
And you know, is many neural networks
are pretty good at handling
up to like a one to 10 ratio of unbalanced data sets.
So people often worry what if an unbalanced data set?
In this example, we have like a one to 30 ratio
and your knowledge may vary.
Sometimes it works, sometimes it won't.
In this case, it didn't work.
But I find that if you have a,
you know, like a one to two ratio,
just usually not that worried about it.
Your network is fine training like that.
Maybe up to one to 10 is when I start to worry
about it being a little bit too unbalanced
for, you know, standard training procedures.
And when I might do something
to make it a little bit more balanced.
But duplicating these samples will be one tactic.
Yes, so penalize false negatives.
Yes, that will work too.
So I think there are a few ways
to train to change the cost function.
You can give the positive examples more weight
or yes, or penalizing false negatives
will be another way to change the cost function.
That will work.
Yes, that will work too.
Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, yes, so you can also decrease
the number of negative examples.
That will work too.
The one downside of that is like it's okay.
I think it's fine to do what you said.
The one slight downside is if you are reducing
the diversity of the negative examples,
then your network has just a little bit
less information to learn from.
I think this is small.
What I just said is a small difference.
So I think that will also work.
It's a quick thing to try.
And I'll tell you what my team actually did.
And I'm telling you this not because
it's a brilliant technique I'm proud of,
but because I just want to tell you the examples
of the types of hacks that actual commercial
machine learning teams do that actually works.
So I'll tell you what we did.
It was very close to duplicating the positive examples,
but we had just a slightly different variation,
which was, we said that instead of the positive example
being the one window where Robert turned on,
just finish.
So here we're having a sequence of labels, right?
Where zero corresponds to is that moment in time
when someone just finished Robert turned on.
And in the architecture I described,
we are detecting a very, very narrow window in time
where someone just finished Robert turned on
and they got to turn on.
But the hack that we used was actually
just extend this out a little bit.
So instead of saying,
did someone just finish saying Robert turned on
and lost 100 milliseconds,
we extended that out to half a second or a second.
And so if someone finished saying Robert turned on
any time they lost half a second,
let's turn on the light, right?
And so this actually generates a few more training examples.
So the reason we did that,
and again, it's a small difference,
is this actually creates a little bit more diversity
in the positive examples than just duplicating it
because now this red rectangle is a positive example
and so is this one and so is this one
and so is this one.
So it just creates a little bit more diversity
in the positive examples.
I expect this will make a very small difference
in the training and the learning algorithms performance,
but it's just, you know,
maybe just slightly better to have slightly,
yes, it covers the space of positive examples,
just a little bit better, make sense?
So, okay, just to keep going with the story,
let's say you do this and now
you still do well on the training site,
95% accuracy on the training site,
but 50% accuracy, so not good enough,
on your dev set, right?
So you fix one problem and another one comes up
and so what do you do next?
Go for it.
Yeah, cool, awesome.
Yep, overfitting, let's use regularization.
Go ahead.
So, right, is it that training and dev set distributions
are not the same?
In this example, because we collected the training
and the dev sets,
if we randomly shuffle between training and dev,
they would be the same distribution, actually.
Yeah, but sometimes there's one other thing I do see,
which is if you, it turns out,
earlier in the history of machine learning,
there was always this assumption of obsession
with making the training set and the dev set
and the test set have the same distribution.
I think it's because if the training set
and the test set have the same distribution,
it's easier to prove theorems,
easier to give guarantees, whatever,
so kind of academic machine learning
there was always this, you know,
theoretical assumption,
which makes the theory work way better.
The training set and your test set
come from the same distribution, right?
It's just like, from a publishing papers point of view,
that makes life much better.
For a practical point of view,
what I see is a lot of the time,
your training set distribution
is just different than your test set distribution.
That's just life because, you know,
it's hard to demand data of a certain sort
and so, for example, one common thing is,
if you do use synthetic data generation,
you can come up with really clever ways
to generate synthetic training data
by using TTS or editing audio or whatever.
There, these techniques let you
generate a massive training set
but the price of that is,
you know, your synthetic data,
I mean, that's not how users talk, right?
Users don't speak synthetic data,
they speak raw data
and so to make sure that your test metric
truly reflects how users will perceive your product,
you know, I would put true data in your test set
and so you end up with a lot of systems
where your training set distribution
is synthetic data or other things you fit it with
and then your test set is
what if the world actually cares more about
and the two distributions is very different
and then I think the question you just asked is,
is the training set distribution
too different from the synthetic data
that is a problem?
Those would be good questions to ask, right?
All right, so if you see this,
this is overfitting
because we're doing great on training set,
not so well on dev,
so one thing to try,
first thing to try is very regularization
so that would be a good thing to try
and then beyond using regularization,
I find that for a lot of speech problems,
if you're overfitting,
getting more data is nice
and so just to share with you,
I know, you know, suggestion of synthetic data earlier,
I'll share with you one thing for synthetic data
that does work,
which we eventually wound up using,
which is, it turns out that,
sorry, this is audio stream, right?
It turns out that there are a lot of,
if you can get audio clips of background noise,
so for example, in this room,
you know, if I'm not,
if I'm quiet,
we can hear a little bit of air conditioning noise, right?
So a lot of rooms have little background noise
or if you're near a highway,
there's cars in the background,
so there are actually most,
most people where they may use the lab,
you know, there's a little bit of background noise.
So if you're able to get audio of background noise
and then additionally record
some very clean audio clips of Robert Turnon,
it turns out that if you take two audio waveforms
and sum them together,
you end up with an audio waveform
that sounds like someone saying this
in the presence of the background noise, right?
I think it's called the superposition property of sound,
but basically sound adds,
which is why if you take two audio clips
and you just add the audio waveforms together,
then you end up with an audio recording
that sounds like both sounds going on at the same time.
So what we can do is take, you know, background noise.
There's actually a lot of audio clips
of background noise on YouTube as well and so on
that check the licensing terms
before you use stuff like that, right?
But there are actually quite a lot of openly licensed audio clips
of, you know, just someone like a quiet,
like a coffee shop noise
or someone sitting in a house studying or whatever.
And so if you can take some background noise audio clips
and then take a clean voice,
someone saying, Robert Turnon, right?
And if you add these two together,
then you end up with background noise,
Robert Turnon and more background noise.
And this becomes a positive example
using the process that we talked about just now.
And if you have a handful of clips of Robert Turnon
and a lot of clips of background noise,
so you can synthesize the phrase Robert Turnon
and use a lot of different types of background noise
and create, you know, a pretty large training set.
It turns out one problem with what I just described
is if you do exactly what I just said,
you won't actually find a Robert Turnon detector,
you end up with a voice activity detection detector
because you have a lot of background noise
and anytime anyone says anything,
the only thing people say is Robert Turnon.
It's much easier to just decide,
is there a loud sound of someone talking
to actually recognize things?
So the other thing we should do
is instead of adding Robert Turnon,
you know, pick a dictionary
or find other types of audio
I think that's where you have to comment just now,
make sure you don't confuse all the things
and add, I don't know,
just someone to say the word,
you know, cardinal or whatever, other words.
So you have a bunch of examples
of people saying words other than Robert Turnon
and then also a bunch of examples
of people saying Robert Turnon.
And by having a handful of clean recordings
of Robert Turnon
and a handful of clean recordings
of people saying other stuff
and synthesizing a data set like this,
you can get a data set
with many thousands of examples
of Robert Turnon pretty efficiently.
And if you train a neural network on this,
you get like a decent wake work
or trigger work detector.
That make sense?
So yeah, right.
So with a process like this,
so this is what working
on a machine learning project feels like, right?
You try something, doesn't work,
like you find out that you have a skewed data set,
be creative in how you create and collect data.
You may find that you have a skewed data set
and it just doesn't work.
You may find it's overfitting.
And I find that it is these,
the ability to drive iterations on a system
that determines how quickly
you can get something to work.
So for the Robert Turnon example,
so if I found that there are a lot of users
that are listening to music,
then I would probably synthesize data
with music in the background
and then have someone say Robert Turnon.
So if you think a lot of users listen to music
and there's a desk lamp,
we want to make sure we catch them
saying Robert Turnon.
Then I would probably synthesize more training data
to include, you know, loudish music
in the background.
Sorry, what are the genre of music?
Yeah, so it turns out that if you have a,
I feel like as a rule of thumb,
if you can have a more diverse set of training data,
it's usually better, right?
So maybe I'm not sure what music my user base
likes to listen to the most.
Is it classical?
Is it rock?
Is it EDM?
Is it whatever?
If you could collect a very rich training set
that includes all of the above
and even more, then usually they'll do better
than going too narrow and risking picking wrong.
Yeah, and the one asterisk to what I said
is so long as you can train a neural network
that's big enough, usually more diverse data,
more data, more diverse data is better.
If your neural network is too small,
then it may lack the capacity
on the intelligence to memorize all this stuff,
which could be a problem
if you need a very small network.
That runs at the edge.
But usually, usually if you have the capacity
to get more rich, more diverse training data,
that ends up delivering better results.
I want to share a view.
So it turns out,
when you're building a machine learning system,
very common experience is
you try something and it doesn't work
and then you have to figure out
all the wonderful ways it could be not working
and then go and fix whatever is not working, right?
And even in this example we went through,
is the training data too skewed?
Is it overfitting?
So you need either regularization or more data
or is it something else?
Or does synthetic data distribution
not match real data distribution?
It turns out that when you train your neural network,
when you train your, when you're building an AI system,
it's really difficult to know in advance
what's going to go wrong next.
I find that in software development,
if I'm writing traditional software,
you kind of control all the code
and so it's more okay to write a spec
and then you just build it
and then it kind of works.
You still need to debug it,
but the bugs are, it's like my own bugs, right?
In contrast,
when you're building a machine learning system,
it's much more like,
I don't know what's going to happen next, right?
Maybe because I don't know what the data will give me,
how to predict how the algorithm will perform.
And so the workflow of machine learning
feels much more like debugging than development.
And by debugging, I mean,
it's a process where you build a system
and you're just repeatedly trying to find
how it doesn't work and fix it.
And if you're trying to do a task that humans can do,
then the bugs or the gaps in performance
is often whatever a human can clearly do,
but the AI system is unable to do.
So, for many machine learning teams
that I've led and worked in,
if you can get the team to a healthy rhythm
of this debugging cycle,
you can make really rapid progress.
So for example, it turns out,
let me give one example.
I've been on teams where we would do the following, right?
And we say morning, afternoon, evening.
So we run our trading jobs at night, right?
And for example, it turns out,
for some of these models we're training,
for speech recognition, it takes, let's say,
it takes four hours, right?
So the training job takes about four hours
to train the neural network.
So training night, in the morning,
we look at the results,
look at the results, do error analysis,
try to figure out what's wrong.
And the afternoon, you know, we write code, right?
To figure out how we're going to fix
what everything we discovered the day before.
And then evening, right before we go home,
we launch the training job.
And then it runs overnight.
And the next morning, we do it again,
and again, and again.
And it turns out that if you can fix one problem a day,
that's actually pretty good.
And within, you know, like, huh.
And then you saw me walk through three,
three or four problems.
When I built this for girl,
there are slightly more problems than that, right?
But I find that you can get a team and take treatments
where you train stuff,
look at the results, figure out,
is this bias, variance, data mismatch?
Oh, actually, this should be cold on good data.
Fix it, you know?
And then the evening before you go home, launch the job.
Maybe if you have time in the evening,
just baby the training job a little bit,
make sure it's still running.
But then come back in the next morning to see how it did.
Then you just do this over and over.
It can make really rapid progress.
And I find there's often this discipline, right?
That, that lets you make progress.
In contrast, the teams that kind of wake up
and they go, huh, what do we do next?
Oh, let's call a meeting this afternoon.
Wait, where's the data?
Okay, I guess we'll meet tomorrow to look at the data.
And then, and then like, oh, our infrastructure is down.
And teams like that move much slower
than the really disciplined teams
that just keep on rolling forward.
And one more observation.
It turns out that your iteration cycle,
sometimes it is driven by this.
So I've worked on machine learning jobs
where it took us about four hours to train a model.
And four hours is long enough.
They want to wait for it.
But, you know, running overnight is just fine.
I've also worked on teams
where a typical training job
took about three weeks on average, right?
And so if it takes three weeks to train a neural network
for a particular type of model we're working on,
then the pacing is very different.
So how long it takes to train a neural network
really drives the pacing of this
where sometimes we would, you know, launch a training job
and then like hope for the best.
We would want to train during those three weeks.
It's not that we do nothing for those three weeks,
but you just go launch a training job.
And then frankly, you know, hope that it works
three weeks later, but we take three weeks.
And then after that, tons of analysis
and debugging and whatever work
that would take us one to two weeks
to set us up for the next training job.
They're going to take us another three weeks
to get the result.
And then we're also parallelizing.
While launching this job,
we're analyzing the job from a previous job
and we've launched a few jobs asynchronously.
But I find that how long it takes,
this is a huge driver for how you do this.
The other end of the spectrum is
if it takes 10 minutes to train a neural network,
then that's wonderful.
You just train it, get the result, train it,
get the coffee, come back, you know,
then do the analysis.
And then the bottleneck is how quickly
can you analyze the data and get more data.
So this really drives the design of this process.
And one of the things that happens is
for a lot of projects, you start off with a small thing
that takes 10 minutes to train,
but then as you get more and more data,
you know, then like you're bigger than,
but now it takes four hours to train.
It goes in bigger.
Then it takes two weeks to train.
It's like, oh, now this thing takes
a month and a half to train.
So I've experienced that as well
where unfortunately as a performance climb,
we decided we had to train bigger
and bigger models with more and more data.
And then it went from this really fantastic
10 minute iterations to these like
months long iterations.
But they just had to be done
because we were training bigger and bigger networks.
Yeah.
We probably didn't stop the model that much.
So sometimes you can look at checkpoints
and if you see that for some reason,
so actually if you're training like a three week job,
you kind of expect the performance
to be at a certain level
after a couple of days or after a week.
And if it's way off,
then before burning another two weeks,
you may ask, is my learning rate clearly wrong?
Or maybe this new data set we try is clearly wrong.
So you can actually start to run
some analyses on the checkpoints
and sometimes we would yank the job
and just kill it.
I don't see that happen very rarely.
Yeah.
Yes.
So what you learn about in the online videos
is transfer learning.
We train a large data set
and then maybe fine tune
on just a much smaller data set.
And then if you process a fine tuning
on a much smaller data set,
it takes half an hour, right?
Then that's great.
Then you can also drive much faster iterations
and that based on that half hours
and let me take back to the training time.
Cool.
One of the reason I obsess about speed
is because it turns out that if the X axis,
imagine you're building a slot
to launch this product, right?
I find that if a team takes twice as long to do it,
they're just much less competitive
in the marketplace, right?
So here's what I mean.
So if this is error and this is months, right?
There's some machine learning systems
that we work on for months
to keep on trying to improve it.
And if this is you
and if a competitor,
say, takes twice as long
to reach the same level.
So instead of taking this long to get here,
they take this long to get here.
Instead of taking this long to get here,
they take twice as long to get here.
So the competitor kind of does that, right?
It just takes twice as long.
You know, they take two days
instead of one day to do something.
But it always takes two days
to do what you would take one day to do.
Then the performance over time looks like this.
And what the customer cares about
at a certain moment in time
is you are so much better than them, right?
So these two X differences in speed
really translates into a massive difference
in the performance of your system
versus someone else's system
in the marketplace.
And I find that the fast-moving teams
are just so much more effective.
And you might think,
yeah, you know, I took two days.
They took one day.
What's the big deal?
Like, the big deal is not that you're a day slower.
The big deal is you're two times slower.
And it's very not just in the marketplace.
It's just not competitive
if you take twice as long
for some applications.
Okay.
All right.
There's one other example I want to cover.
Let me try to do that quickly.
So what I've talked about so far
is speech recognition, wake word detection,
which is more of an end-to-end
deep learning system
where your input audio
goes to the neural network.
And in this outputs,
there's this RTO robot turn on, right?
So the entire system
you're trying to build
is just a single neural network.
For a lot of applications you build,
you end up building pipelines
or sometimes call them cascades.
So I'm going to use the term pipelines.
We saw one example of this last time
where to detect people
coming up to unlock the door
with face recognition,
we had video that fed to visual activity detection
to see if anyone is even in front of it.
And then that fed to neural network
to recognize is this an authorized person
and then 01 to say
is this a person
that we should unlock the door for, right?
What I want to do is use a different example
of a pipeline of an AI deep researcher.
So it turns out all of the leading alarm,
well, almost all of the leading alarm providers
have deep researchers
where you can ask a query
or go and search the internet,
look at a lot of web pages
and come back and synthesize
a very thoughtful report, right?
And so, yeah,
but I actually use the open AI deep researcher
quite a lot.
I think that I know some of the team
that built it really well,
but I think some of us also did a good job.
But so, you know,
you input a query like,
this is example I'm taking
from the agented AI course online.
But input the query like
show me the latest research on black holes, right?
Some query like that.
And then one thing you might do
is take a query like whatever, right?
Black hole research.
And then use an LLM,
use a large model
to generate search terms
to feed to a web search engine.
So it may generate a few terms like,
you know, black hole research
latest in, I don't know,
astronomy and black holes or whatever.
So generate a handful of search terms.
This then call out to a web search engine,
be it server, Google,
data go, Bing, I don't know,
I used to really quite a lot.
But multiple, actually,
actually more and more
web search engines designed for AI
rather than for humans,
which I think is pretty neat.
So this can call,
call the web search engine
and then fetch the top URLs.
Oh, sorry.
I mean, I fetched the top pages,
other than the top URLs.
So the web search engine returns 10 pages.
You may not want to fetch all 10 of them.
You can read the snippets,
decide which ones are most relevant.
Again, maybe with an LLM,
with a large language model,
to decide what are the pages
you want to download.
So just like a human,
you know, do a web search.
I won't click every single link.
I'll take a glance
and then decide which ones I'm going to click.
So identify and fetch the top URLs
and then feed all that into
right here,
into writing,
and this gives the final output, right?
So this is a, by the way,
I think this is a more traditional
de-researcher article,
sorry, de-researcher architecture.
The more modern de-researcher article,
architectures that the system
decide when to do more web search,
when to fetch more web pages
and are more, you know,
autonomous, more agenting.
But this is what the early
de-researcher architectures look like.
There's more of a linear pipeline.
There are more modern architectures
where the system will fetch some pages
and autonomously decide,
do I need to go back
and do more research
on some of my topics
and figure it out a few times?
But this would be like a,
you know, pretty decent,
basic de-researcher, right?
And it turns out that
if you actually build this,
there, one of the,
in the speech recognition system,
Robert Turnon lamp example,
we talk a lot about
how to improve one component,
which is the neural network.
If you have a pipeline like this,
the other thing you need to do,
which is pretty important,
is to decide
of all the different components
in the pipeline,
which one do you want
to focus your attention on, right?
So I find that one thing
that makes a huge difference
in a team's performance
is, again, being able to drive
a disciplined evaluation
and error analysis process
to decide what to work on.
I find that a lot of machine learning
is not, you know,
wildly doing things
to see what works.
There's actually a very thoughtful,
very disciplined process
where with the system,
maybe it's not doing
as well as we wish,
so we should look at it to decide.
It turns out lots of things
could be wrong.
Is it generating search terms
that aren't quite right, right?
Or maybe we're using
a web search engine
that is returning results
that aren't that good.
So, for example,
is my web search engine
comprehensive enough,
or is it just, you know,
maybe I picked a lower cost
web search service or something
that's just not returning
the latest materials?
It turns out,
for some internet articles,
many web search engines
would do really well,
but if you ever want to fetch news,
really fresh news,
there's actually a lot of difference
in the performance.
Some web search engines
are much better
at having really fresh content.
Some just don't update as frequently,
so do I need to switch
web search engines?
Or am I successfully identifying
the best web pages to fetch?
So if I have black hole signs,
you know, I think nasa.gov
is probably a very
authoritative web page,
but if a web search engine
returns, you know,
like, I don't know,
bobsbackdownastronomyblog.com, right?
That's less authoritative
than nasa.gov.
Am I correctly fetching
the most authoritative
scientific articles
versus whatever is hyped up,
you know, or maybe like,
am I fetching a lot of
random TikTok videos,
you know, rather than
really scientific authoritative things?
And then lastly,
given all this information,
am I writing a thoughtful article,
right, with an LM
from the final research output?
So it turns out that
with a pipeline like this,
there are lots of steps
that could go wrong,
and your ability to
decide what is the components
you should focus your effort on,
that's a massive driver
of your productivity
in improving a system like this.
And the good news is
that there's actually
one other thing I've seen.
Sometimes I've seen a few
experienced machine learning people,
it's actually one thing I've seen.
Sometimes a team will
build a system like this,
and if it's a less experienced team,
they'll build a system,
it's not quite working,
try to decide what to do next.
One thing I've seen many times is
if you get a few senior
machine learning people around,
as I've seen this quite a few times,
sometimes the students
on the project may build
a system like this.
If you get a few, you know,
experienced professors
to look at the system,
you find that our opinions
on what to do next,
there's remarkably little variance, right?
So you find that many,
you know, experienced AI people
will look at it and will go,
well, based on what it seems,
we think this is a problem,
or this is wrong,
we should try this.
It's not that we always agree
with each other 100%,
but the variance is much less
than you might think.
And to me that, you know,
I think there's a methodology
behind how to approach
these problems,
whereas the variance
and what to try next
among less experienced engineers
is much larger, right?
So to me, I think there's actually,
if you have a systematic way
of doing error analysis,
to figure out
where it's actually underperforming,
you know, experienced people
all kind of,
doesn't mean experienced people
are always right,
there's just no variance, right?
But then there really is a methodology
to figure out what to do next.
And one of the key ideas
is error analysis.
And I talk about this
on online videos as well,
but this is so important
and we'll just go through.
And one thing to do
is to look at the outputs
of each of these intermediate steps
and it's one of these things,
I know I'll say it,
you probably even agree
it's a good idea,
but the percentage of people
that actually do it
when the time comes
are found to be far lower
than 100%, right?
But there's just, you know,
take a handful of queries,
be it, is it latest
in black hole science
or should I rent
or buy an apartment
or, you know,
what's the, what are,
help me make fun plans
for a weekend in Santa Cruz,
whatever, some handful of queries
for a deep researcher.
And then look at what search terms
it generates
and see if it makes sense.
Look at the web pages and fetches,
see if they look good.
Look at the top pages and fetch
and see if the top web pages selected
is similar
or if it's materially different
than what you would pick.
Like my example,
one of this decides to fetch
Bob's Backup Astronomy page.com
rather than nasa.gov, right?
Then you go, okay,
maybe I need to change how to do that.
And then also look at the final writing
to see given the source articles
is it writing the appropriate articles.
And what I find is
for a process like this,
you know, it turns out error analysis
is often a very manual process
because when the system isn't performing
error analysis or gap analysis
is often a manual process of
figuring out what a human would do
that is better than what the AI system would do.
And we're trying to inject knowledge
from the human into the AI system.
So because AI doesn't have this knowledge yet,
usually you do need a human time to do this.
And I know, you know,
and people are talking about automating
some of this
and maybe there'll be problems there.
But so far I find error analysis,
it just takes human to look at it
and have the insights into
where AI system is doing something different
than an expert human would be.
And it's that insight
that then points you in the direction
for how to improve it.
And so often I would build a spreadsheet like this
where I have a query that is,
you know, black hole science.
Another one, do I rent versus buy,
you know, in whatever, San Francisco
or, you know, weekend activities in Santa Cruz, right?
Whatever, just have, I don't know,
maybe up to a hundred.
I find that I often have patients
look at up to a hundred examples,
beyond a hundred,
sometimes more than a hundred,
but it's somewhere between ten and a hundred.
Have a list of queries
and have a list of steps.
And so the steps would be, right, search terms,
what's that, web search,
fetch pages.
So this is what it feels like to do error analysis.
It is a labor intensive process
because there's a process of
identifying where a human outperforms AI
to try to close the gap, right?
Just do this over and over.
But so what I would do is,
I'll sit down often with a spreadsheet
in front of me open like this,
and I will run, you know,
black hole science through the whole system
and then just read,
are the search terms satisfactory?
And if I'm not an expert in black hole science,
I may need to get an expert
or do a bit of work to figure that out.
But if I find that the search terms
to send to a web search engine
are completely satisfactory,
then I just say, okay, this one's good.
Then given those search terms,
I'll look at the web search results and say,
huh, did the web search engine
retrieve reasonable things?
And it looks good, then great.
And then I look at,
did my system, maybe in LLM,
did it make a good choice
in the top web pages to actually go and fetch?
And maybe I found this retrieving,
it chose to retrieve Bob's backup astronomy blog,
but skip NASA.gov.
Then I'll say, okay, there's a problem there, right?
And then often to make a note, you know,
Bob instead of NASA, right?
Just to kind of just take notes on what you're seeing.
And then I'll say, given these sources,
is this writing okay?
Maybe it's okay.
And then the process is to take a handful,
somewhere between 10, 20, and 100 of articles
where the performance is subpar.
And it's called error analysis
because I want to focus on where it's underperforming, right?
So there's some articles
where it's doing a great job on,
I would tend to pay less attention to those.
But I focus on finding anywhere from 10, 20, to 100 queries,
where it's clearly underperforming
what I think a human should be doing
or what I hope should do.
And then going through to just try to get a sense
of how often the hotspots
are in different parts of the pipeline.
And so maybe for rent versus buy,
I might say, boy,
there's a really authoritative blogger
that talks about this,
but somehow web search misses.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm using the wrong web search engine.
We can in Santa Cruz, yes,
it's buying into some hyped up tourist things
rather than actually finding
locally interesting webpages and so on.
And then by doing this for 20, 30, 50 queries,
you can then start to get a sense
of where the hotspots are, right?
So again, all of these are subpar results.
I'm focusing on queries
where the performance is not good enough.
And then if I find that, you know,
I don't know, 40% of the time
it's failing to fetch the top webpages.
Only 5% of the time, right,
it's failing to do that.
Actually, because of the issues.
They find that 70% of the time
I'm really not happy with this.
5% of the time web search is not good enough.
You know, maybe 20% of the time
search terms are wrong
and maybe 20% of the time
the writing is not good enough.
These don't have to add up to 100%.
Sometimes you have problems in one column.
But if this is what it turns out to be,
then we'll go, well, clearly a lot of the,
my dissatisfaction of results
is because it's just not choosing good pages
from the web search to return.
So let me go focus on that.
And the thing about a lot of machine learning systems
is you just don't know
if you don't do this error analysis ahead of time
in terms of what component to focus on.
And so I find that teams that know
how to drive this process systematically
and it sometimes takes us hours.
And we're that, you know, daily schedule thing.
Sometimes it takes us a few hours
to go through this process to reach conclusions.
But then the benefit of spending like whatever,
you know, three, four hours on this
is that it can save you weeks
of otherwise heading in the wrong direction.
So teams can drive this
evalus and error analysis process
in a very methodological way.
You're much better picking what direction to work in
and that allows your team to go way faster.
And there's way more than a 2x difference.
So I've actually literally visited teams
that have been working on something for six months.
I go, like, gee, you know,
I could have told you six months ago
this wasn't going to cut it, right?
And then imagine if this was the problem,
we're not writing the right web pages,
but, you know, for some reason,
the team kept on trying out different web search engines.
Maybe there's someone trying to sell
a new web search service to you.
So, you know, spend a lot of time with the sales team,
do a lot of integration with the web search.
There's actually more web search services
than most people know, right?
So, and I actually swap between them
whenever I feel like it.
So imagine you spend all your time
trying to come up with a better web search service,
you know, for six months,
at least entirely possible.
Then you could just,
it just won't move the needle
for the overall performance,
which is why the cyber error analysis process
is so important, right?
I walked through this with the example of one pipeline.
The online videos go through other examples as well,
but both building deep learning pipelines
is for kind of AI agentic pipelines.
I think this is a very important concept to master.